Представники 23-х держав ЄС підписали декларацію
про наміри брати участь у "постійній структурній
співпраці з питань безпеки та оборони" - PESCO.
Представлено загалом понад 50 проектів у галузі безпеки,
однак розпочати планують з десяти.
Серед них - створення європейського медичного командування,
центру навчання офіцерів, служби військового
забезпечення, кіберзахисту тощо.
PESCO матиме власний оборонний фонд.
Проект розцінюють як один з кроків на шляху
створення європейськогооборонногосоюзу.
У Брюсселі називають цей крок історичним, адже
досі військової співпраці всередині
самого Євросоюзу не було.
Рішення створити PESCO свідчить про те,
що ЄС рухається у напрямку самостійності у питанні
забезпечення власної оборони замість того,
щоб розраховувати у цьому питанні винятково на НАТО.
Разом з тим у Брюсселі наголошують, що PESCO
не стане конкурентом Північноатлантичного
альянсу, а доповнюватиме його.
Серед причин, що підштовхнути країни ЄС до
створення ПЕСКО - політика Дональда Трампа.
Саме непередбачуваність американського
президента змушує ЄС не покладатися на США.
Друга - Brexit, оскільки британці досі були
головними противниками створення
європейських збройних сил.
Крім того, до обрання Емануеля Макрона
президентом Франції Париж також був
прихильником незалежної оборонної політики.
Тепер після підписання декларації про наміри
остаточне рішення щодо започаткування PESCO
має бути ухвалене у грудні 2017 року.
Участь у реалізації цих намірів є
добровільною для членів ЄС.
Ірландія, Португалія та Мальта досі розмірковують,
чи брати участь в PESCO.
Дві країни - Великобританія та Данія - відмовилися.